China's tit-for-tat tariffs on us made
Goods have come into effect the import
tax on over 5,000 items is now 25%
Beijing is responding to hiked u.s.
tariffs on 200 billion dollars worth of
Chinese goods also earlier in May at
Donald Trump band
Chinese tech giant Huawei pressuring
allies to do the same reports now
suggest China is planning to mirror this
move compiling a blacklist of u.s.
enterprises to counter the impact of
Chinese tariffs Trump has promised
subsidies to the US farmers something
China expert Andrew Leung says won't
help much obviously as far as the income
of the American farmers are concerned
that could be subsidized by the trauma
administration but this cannot be
indefinite don't forget that China is
the by far the largest market for
American agricultural products and then
discontinuing subsidizing it's not it's
not going to make the farmers happy then
obviously it's going to have a
significant impact on president Trump's
political support base meanwhile the
u.s. acting defense secretary took a
swipe at China while speaking at the
Asia Pacific summit in Singapore some in
our region are choosing to act contrary
to the principles and norms that have
benefited us all they destabilize the
region deploying advanced weapons
systems to militarized disputed areas
destabilizing the peaceful status quo by
threatening the use of force to compel
rivals into conceding claims you know
we're not going to ignore it Chinese
behavior okay I think in the past people
have kind of tiptoed around that this
highlights the kind of rochester's trade
but a fight for regional dominance in
the asia-pacific
at least the range of rivalry and and of
course that as some include stray
includes the military needed a lot of
other countries would be caught in this
for a between its two pounds
you